foreign
as an evolutionist what matters is that
genes are causal agents contradicting
Dennis's statement
um
they are not active causes they are
active causes how how do we ever
recognize a Cause
well I think the answer is this
we do an experiment we manipulate you
cannot show that something's a cause
unless you manipulate and it's a very
trivial example suppose you have
a hypothesis that a crows every
time a church clock
um told
So You observe a correlation that the
the the the clock told and the and the
crows
uh is that is is it causal the only way
to be sure is to do an experiment climb
up into the Clock Tower and change the
clock or manipulate the clock ideally
make the clock toe at random
and then if the crows uh then
you've shown a causal link
in the case of genes we know that if you
if you mutate a gene then it will change
the phenotype
more importantly for an evolutionist
that change Will Go On to the Next
Generation and the next and the next and
the next and potentially forever
um whereas if you change anything else
no matter how important it may be
causally in the embryology of the animal
if you break a leg
circumcise a penis do anything else it
will not be transmitted into future
generations and that's the crucial
difference I love that introduction
Richard because 30 years ago I did
precisely that experiment
let's go through it carefully because I
think the experiment is important and
this was work done with my colleague
from Italy Dario de Francesco and what
we discovered in that work about 30
years ago was that a particular protein
and therefore the gene it's an hcn
protein so it's an hcn Gene that was
responsible for the great majority of
the cardiac Rhythm actually can be
knocked out all the protein blocked and
hardly any change in rhythm
the association levels between the
Crow and the the Bell or whatever it was
I've forgotten now and the association
levels are actually generally with a few
outlier genes that are very clearly
terribly important to the organism they
can be overridden by the rest of the
organism you see and that's exactly what
was happening in our cardiac pacemaker
work what we showed is the the Rhythm
goes like that you know that's what's
happening in your heart now and it goes
with a particular frequency let's give
it 80 80 beats per minute you block this
particular component which we know as a
matter of physiology contributes 80
percent of the rhythm-generating
electric current you knock it out
there's hardly any change in frequency
now I think what is happening is that
organisms are terribly robust they know
how to manage with whatever genes they
happen to have so what I think is
happening there is simply that another
network is operating we actually have
identified that Network too so we've
done all of those experiments already
and I think the genome-wide association
study people have done this endlessly
During the period in which for what is
it now about 20 years of genome
sequencing and what we find is that the
actual Association levels are quite low
that is a wonderful fact from an
embryological point of view from an
epigenetic point of view
but nevertheless
in the long run as an evolutionist in
the long run as the generations go by no
matter how clever even if organisms do
do change what effect genes have and I'm
sure they do nevertheless in the long
run what matters is changes in gene
frequencies in populations and I'm
talking as an evolutionist now not as a
physiologist or as an embryologist
perhaps we could say that genes do two
quite different things
in embryology what they do is influence
phenotypes in highly complicated ways
including the ways you've just
enunciated
but for an evolutionary point of view
what matters is the ones that are still
here Ten Thousand Years hence